new report reveals the Biden
Administration drastically watered down
the vetting process specifically for
Chinese Nationals who illegally crossed
our border according to an April 2023
email obtained by The Daily Caller CBP
agents were told to drop the number of
interview questions from 40 to just five
joining me now is John Ratcliffe former
US Director of National Intelligence
under President Trump John that email
reportedly came after a record setting
year of Terror watch list encounters
talk to
me yeah well uh just like everything
else Joe Biden has has has done at the
border is he's failed to confront
National Security threats Terror watch
list suspects went up by 7,000 per and
as a result of the email that you just
talked about the number of Chinese
Nationals Crossing illegally at the US
Mexico border went up by 1,000% this
past year uh they changed the process uh
from what should have been a half a day
of interrogation to a five Question
10minute Interview uh to then release um
thousands of Chinese Nationals who have
come here illegally into the country um
and the problem you know take just last
month judge uh 5,000 uh came through
just last month alone of that number
judge the concern is that 85% of those
were single men um military AED men and
you know the intelligence communities
are now at a point where we're we're not
really even concerned about uh whether
you know uh some significant percentage
of that uh are here under pla or PRC
orders um it's just a question of how
many are we talking about thousands and
it poses a a tremendous National
Security concern clearly I John just
before this show secretary Alejandro
mayorcas talked with our own Brett Bear
about the the Border take a
listen you do think it's a crisis
now Brett it is a challenge uh that uh
we have been addressing vigorously with
John how can he still not admit it's a
crisis well I mean he's like every other
Biden Administration official in terms
of you know they've gone from it's not a
problem it's not a problem at all
there's no crisis to well uh you know
we've The Border's secure but uh if it's
if if there is a problem it's not our
fault I mean that's just kind of how
this Administration has been operating
it's not just mayorcas it's blinkin it's
uh you know the entire National Security
apparatus and it's it's why we Face such
a grave national security threat when we
talk about our border here the concern
judge is that you know uh hopefully the
American people will um remove Joe Biden
from office but you know you can reverse
economic policies the cost of gas and
and food can come down but if you if you
inherit national security problems if
you have bad people that are behind the
walls in the gates uh you've got a
national all right John thanks so much
for being with us tonight hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else